what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking Thrones I am here with
gray area and today we are going to
continue with our predictions for bran
Stark in part one we discussed some of
the things we think bran can do to help
win the Great War now that Sam Tarly and
bran Stark are working together there is
a very good chance Sam can help bran
find a specific time in the past that
may have some of the answers to
defeating the night king Sam was the one
who helped bran figure out the truth
about Jon Snow's parents so now that Sam
has all these books and documents about
the long night I think he will tell bran
where to look in order to see how the
others were stopped for the first time
so what I want to ask you is what do you
think bran can go back in time and see
they may be able to help them today do
you think he can see how the last hero
was able to end the long night the first
time or do you think he can find out
more about the origins of the White
Walkers or do you think it might be
something else it could be the last hero
if it was mentioned on the show I'm
trying to think of things that were
mentioned on the show specifically it
could be he could go back to the first
long night I think he needs to go back
to the pact the pact between first men
and children I think he needs to go back
to that to see what was the premises of
this pact like what did the children
promise and see what what they said they
would do to defeat the White Walkers he
could go back and see the last hero but
I think because they keep they showed
that Jade compendium yeah on there and
they talked about this Ozora high
character on the show or the prince that
was promised so I think they could go
back to that time but I don't know like
can he access Essos
can he see what what happened in Essos I
think that he can that is a good
question I don't think we have seen him
do that yet but I believe when he is
able to fully harness his powers he will
be able to everything he sees is stolen
fragments right now but he does have
access to the entire history of planet
toast basically
yeah because I know like in dances
dragon he said you can see use the
weirwoods to see but once you're
stronger you'll be able to see wave way
farther than that cuz like in his coma
dream he's all the way in a shy I feel
like that he's gonna have the power to
see that far and then so it looks like
so many things that he could go back and
see but because the Jade compendium was
brought up and we saw that we saw Gilly
with that book oh that that's gonna be a
book that that's that Sam took with him
I think they are basically trying to go
in that direction what Jon being that
guy yeah I agree
yeah what did you think it was kind of
it could be the last hero that he goes
Breck indeed I do think it's a strong
possibility we have seen Gilly holding a
book about the legends of the long night
based on the story we have been given in
the books we know that it was when the
last heroes set out to find that chose
another forest in order to stop the
others when the last year were found
that chose another forest they were able
to get the fighting to stop somehow and
the long night ended the last he must
have done something to get the others to
stop fighting or fleeing north and I
think Sam may find that in one of the
books he has then he can tell bran to go
back and look to see how it was done
yeah in the books and and I just in the
video that I just did we I talked about
this a little bit but him is reading
like he's looking for stuff on the
others in the long night and he can't
find anything and he's basically saying
like all these books are written by
septons like they're just passed down
and they don't make any sense because
knights are riding around when Knights
didn't even exist and kings were living
for like 300 years and stuff like that
so he was saying that the first men only
left runes and something else but I was
wondering if bran
could go back to when those drawings
were painted in that cave because
ultimately Sam did find that dragonglass
cave or that cave of dragonglass
in a book at the Citadel so I was
thinking that brand might go back and
see where they drew when they drew that
that was drawn in the times that this
long night was going on that could be
where he goes back at it's just it's
like so hard when you're talking about
brand to know what's going on with him
because he's so awkward some people and
I think this is very plausible for brand
is that some people say that he's not
even brand like it's not branded
somebody else but his Brad's body that
is possible I guess the three-eyed Raven
did tell bran it was time for brand to
become him then we did see the
three-eyed Raven disintegrate then they
tell benjin the three-eyed Raven is dead
but benjin said he lives again
and when Mira is talking to bran at
Winterfell she tells him he died back in
that cave and she was referring to bran
so that is definitely something to
consider because you have to wonder who
the hell brain really is now right she
died and and you noticed that when he's
with benjin he's drinking blood yup
that's right he was drinking rabbit's
blood in the show so it's weird like and
then just the way that brand acted bran
doesn't really have to be dead to be
sharing his body with someone else
what do you mean exactly okay so when
brand goes into Hodor even though Hodor
is considered simple-minded and that's
why it's easy allegedly for a brand to
go and Makoto was not dead Hodor was
still there right bran can and um bran
can feel Hodor inside like when he's
inside Hodor skin he can feel him being
scared and not one hit there and all
those things but it doesn't affect
the that he used they'll uses his body
and basically bran doesn't have to be
dead for the three-eyed Raven to go into
his skin okay I see what you're saying
now I actually did see someone make that
theory I can't quote all of the evidence
they had but it did make a lot of sense
I don't necessarily believe the theory
but there is enough evidence to make a
good case for it I think yeah my video
that I did about it was about Benjen not
being benjin but I mean yeah I did see
the evidence for brand sharing his body
because in the books it always seems
like Glen Raven is priming him to steal
his body I don't really know if they
should I don't think the show is gonna
do that because they didn't really show
any of that Jojen pay stuff and all the
weird things that happened do you think
the Bloodraven is kind of like Chucky
and he doesn't want some new body let's
play hide the soul bring him I'm sorry
brain I just got to get out of his
goddamn shirt I'm gonna need a no I know
I don't think I don't think it's like
that I mean I don't discredit those
theories though like there's no way you
can you can say either way what's going
on because they don't give us that much
evidence and it's like bran is just
weird it is very weird and we still
don't know how that is gonna end in the
books even though the television show
left out some of those pieces of the
theory we still don't know which
direction George is gonna take this in
that is interesting though and I think
that's where some people start thinking
bran could be the night king
I hate that I do not want him to be the
my king look he's the night king I would
be shocked I would be shocked because
I've seen the case for it and I'm not
saying that there isn't that is it that
it's complete tin foil because I don't
think that it's complete Tim Boyle I
think the people that put it together
it's pretty solid
yeah game of theories made that video
and I thought it was done really well
yeah in X's he's good at that
yeah and I love next but uh no I don't
think brain is I mean if he is the night
came he would not be the night king in
the books the evidence that's used for
the theory is mainly is it's only show
evidence yeah
there's nothing from the books that
support it and in the books you're not
even sure if the night king is a
physical man yeah there was something
else I wanted to ask you do you think we
will see bran have any kind of mental
tug-of-war what the night king as this
war progresses I I really want that to
happen I think that we get kind of a
glimpse of that when bran is inside the
weirwood net and he's where the night
king is and we see that the night king
is powerful enough to come into his
vision like he's either looking at a
vision of the past or the present he's
not really there but the night king is
able to interact with him that leads me
to believe that the night king may be a
green seer or warg
I talked about this a little bit and
basically there's a figure a legendary
figure in the world of Ice and Fire
called the warg King and he basically
had an army of like green Searson and
things like that so I could see like a
battle of the vines going on and I could
see that as possibly being
brand would be the night king mmm how
bran would be the night king is by
getting trapped inside his body yeah
yeah I do too like that that could
definitely happen and I actually think
as of right now I think the night king
is actually more powerful than Brian
like what you said where he entered his
vision and he was able to grab bran and
when brand sent the flock of birds or
the murder of crows whatever people call
it north of the wall and how the night
king and looked up at it and basically
the birds almost exploded and brains
snapped out of it and was scared to
death so I think my King kind of has
he's one up on bran right now but yeah
bran ultimately harnesses those powers
then he will be able to stop the night
king but I think right now the night
king has brand beat and he has brand
scared yeah I agree with I agree with
all that because I mean he's got to be
more powerful than brand because Brandon
is just really finding out what he is
and and just harness just now harnessing
the power that he has and to be honest
bran is a green seer greenseers get
their strength from blood yeah so I
doubt he's drinking on any blood at
Winterfell no we definitely haven't seen
it for real oh can you imagine if Songza
walked in a room and bran had like blood
like a blood mustache should be like one
sister has a finger bags the other
brother is drinking blood and having
weird with visions and I'm just over
here what's going on so um let's see
I'll try to wrap this up do you think
bran will have to sacrifice himself to
stop the night king
that's a good question and I never
thought about brand sacrificing himself
I don't think you'll have to sacrifice
himself I think he already kind of did
sacrifice himself if bran is really the
three-eyed Raven now then he sacrificed
who he was to become the three-eyed
Raven
that's absolutely right he already has
made a huge sacrifice he gave up his old
life to become the new three-eyed Raven
Jon Snow is trying to defeat the night
King because he knows no one else is
gonna take it as serious as him but bran
knows he has to be the one to help
defeat the night king he knows he has
this connection with the night King John
really has no idea how important he
actually is until brain is able to
reveal that just like he said earlier in
the video bran might find out that John
does have this really big role to play
because he is both ice and fire I agree
with that a hundred percent and I think
that's exactly why bran is so important
and he's gonna be the key he's gonna be
the key to everything let me ask you one
more thing before we end the video at
the end of this story after all the wars
are over
some people believe magic will die too
it could have something to do with all
the dragons dying but if that happens in
Melisandre would let's say lose all of
her powers and the warlocks would lose
all of their powers and everything else
do you think that means bran will die
too I don't know that Graham will die
and well I mean if magic is completely
eradicated from the whole planet O's
then I guess bran would die but I'm not
sure what the weirwood gods or the old
gods I'm not sure what they are like is
what they do is it magic or is it like
something bigger than that like some
kind of holy deity like a God because if
it's a God then I wouldn't consider it
magic right
so if it if it's if it's but if it's
solely magic then yeah he would die
I feel like magic in the beginning of
our story magic wasn't really a thing
dragons weren't weren't around
direwolves weren't around children of
the forest weren't around like magic
wasn't talked about at all right you
know and I really only started to
increase when the comet came and then
the Dragons were born then it really
started to ramp up right so we still had
we still had the children of the forest
and we still had Bloodraven north of the
wall in his cave we still had all that
without having magic at the forefront
that is a very good point when magic was
at its weakest the children of the
forest were still around they were just
hiding and bloodraven was still around
he was even visiting brain before the
dragons were born in that case if magic
did die off and I think bran would still
live he just may lose some of his powers
at the most because he really wouldn't
need them anymore after that either yeah
he wouldn't if they eradicate the White
Walkers which I don't know that if
that's what they're gonna do I don't
know if they're gonna be able to
completely destroy them I feel like the
last time that they fought the White
Walkers it says they sent them fleeing
to the icy north so they sent them
running and they they left them alone
but they didn't kill them they didn't
eradicate them they didn't wipe them off
the face of the earth
but if they're if there's one white
Walker left at the end of this then
brain still needs to be alive yeah
because then all you would need is
someone else sacrificing babies to them
and they could grow their army again yep
and bran will need to train the next
three-eyed Raven I'd be crazy just
having a cycle just keep going and going
and going that's why I think when this
this story ends the current story at
least in the show I think the night King
needs to be defeated completely that way
it breaks this cycle and ultimately
breaks the wheel
and I I think as well and I want that's
what I want to happen all right ladies
and gentlemen that is the end of our
brand Starck video I want to thank gray
area for coming on my channel I really
enjoyed our conversation make sure you
go subscribe to her channel that way you
can check out some of her other great
videos the link to her channel will be
done in the description of this video
she will be releasing a video we did
together about Arya Stark and that
should be up on her channel very soon we
also recorded a video about Melisandre
and I'm gonna be uploading that either
tomorrow or the day after that you
definitely don't want to miss that one
but I want to thank everyone for
stopping by and checking out our
collaboration let us know what you think
down in the comment section I also want
to thank everyone on patreon who
continue to support this channel during
the long night it really means a lot to
me I hope you all have a great day
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]